about our democracy for a minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well hello out there and good afternoon
today we have a special guest on let's
talk the tony michaels podcast
of course it's three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern you know what time
that is
it's time for let's talk the tony
michaels podcast and i
am the tony michaels
and again we have a special guest today
i'm very excited to have this guest
uh he's a fellow tiki talker uh is
everyone you know tick tock tick tock
tick tock ah it's a children's dancing
app it may be a children's dancing app
but there's plenty of [ __ ] politics
to go around over there and you guys
know i like the tiki talks and i like
the the political ticky talks so i
wanted to bring someone on who has done
a great job at uh his
his videos and his sketches over on tic
tac his name is gabe sanchez he's
originally from chicago illinois but he
lives in los angeles uh he is he is an
actor and comedian and he does great
videos fantastic um and some of my
favorite are when he's making fun of the
pace eaters and actually you know what
speaking of that let's play one of my
favorite videos that gabe has done about
horse space not taking the vaccine i
don't know what's in it well you could
just google it except the vaccine is
approved for emergency use only it's not
fdr approved i think you mean fda
approved whatever same thing well you're
in luck because the fda recently
approved the final vaccine i'll just
stick with what works and what's that
regeneron you can't be serious that is
literally approved for emergency use
only oh is that a problem because sleepy
joe didn't give his approval huh you
sound like a sheep oh what are you
eating hygromectan as in the dewormer
for livestock
and you just called me a sheep now what
are you eating heartwarm medicine for
cats oh my god just get the vaccine no
so so i don't know if gabe is fdr
approved or not but we are going to
bring him in today on the show whether
he's approved or not uh so uh welcome
hey gabe how are you
good thank you so much for having me
yeah hey no problem no problem we're
happy to have you here and we can't wait
we've got a few more videos uh if if you
don't mind to queue up here um i know
you sent us one of your latest videos
but i have a few more favorites that i'd
like to play um but introduce yourself
tell us who you are
yeah so uh my name is gabe sanchez uh i
like like tony said i'm from chicago i
live in la right now and um you know uh
before the pandemic was doing live shows
comedy you know acting and and now as
things are beginning to slowly come back
in doing those things again
um
but yeah in the meantime i pretty much
talked to myself in videos as you saw
so so you like the tiki talks right
yeah they're great the tiki talks are
great you know i i originally joined at
the beginning of the pandemic and
couldn't
quite get into the whole dance thing but
it really wasn't my you know cup of tea
big big secret gabe big secret i
actually went back to the beginning of
your account and i checked out some of
the original videos and i i decided not
to play them here but i'll tell you if
anyone out there is a big gabe sanchez
fan it is it is totally worth the laughs
to go back
and look at some of gabe's first videos
and how he evolved into the sketch
videos and speaking of that you have you
now we're recording this before this
premiere and when this does air
of course this video will already be out
on tick tock and twitter and the social
media sphere right
but i do have your brand new video that
you have not released yet of course
when we do air this it will be released
but i feel like we're premiering it here
on the recording so let me play that
because i want to i want to ask you
about a few things on it about on the
other side
come here me you looking for that covert
treatment oh no i'm getting the vaccine
don't get the gym
don't get the jab okay that's how bill
gates is gonna track you bill gates
doesn't care what we're doing look man
whatever you want i got it okay you want
to inject some bleach what the [ __ ] all
right fine but what about
hydroxychloroquine that was debunked
i've also got ivermectin the human kind
not that horseshit that was also the
bomb that was proven to be ineffective
what yeah they used to fake data in the
research [ __ ] well i've also got
betadine as in the iodine antiseptic
used for minor scrapes and cuts yeah
just drink it up and poof no more
coronavirus fetadine is antibacterial
not antiviral well my dad's friend's
cousin sister's coworker is a doctor and
they post it on facebook that it works
i'm just gonna leave wait wait wait wait
don't leave okay i got one more and i
think you'll love this one
all right it's an exotic treatment from
south america brazilian viper veto
brazilian viper yeah just one bite in
your chair watch
holy
i can feel the cure flowing through my
veins no that's the toxic venom
uh i'm gonna stick with the vaccine
[Laughter]
not that not that it's the humankind not
that horseshit that's fantastic so i'm
so glad you made that video that that
that really it pulls all the great cures
that these morons have on one video so
how do you
what is your process like are you like
hey here's my idea and then you write it
out i mean how do you make these tick
tocks tell us tell us a little bit about
that
yeah so i'm pretty much like uh
i've got
like twitter trending you know kind of
like sitting there in the background to
figure like all right what's what is
being brought up because i don't there's
so much [ __ ] out there that i
i i'll miss it right and i feel like
twitter is a great resource to kind of
like bubble those things to the surface
um
and then from there or or even before
that if i catch something online or i'm
reading an article i'm just like this is
uh
so messed up or this is so extreme or
this is so ridiculous whatever it is
because i think you know over the last
year or
year plus two years three years whatever
uh
uh
satire
and parody like normally you'd be like
yeah i'm gonna hide into like a 10 or
11. but then like when reality is
heightened
already base level to like 10 or 11 then
you've got to like take it beyond
that to like a 15 16 maybe a 20
depending on what you're trying to do to
get the point across
uh it's hard because you're like always
competing with something in the news
that is
you're like that would never happen like
thinking back like i never imagined this
timeline to be this [ __ ] up
uh this crazy and so the process is
really like
seeing what's what's trending online
what people are talking about you know
is there a story that's not really being
talked about in trying to bring
attention to it or
uh reading up for in this case reading
up on stories of
uh of what an anti-vaxxer will take
but or accept the vaccine right and it's
like the other ones are like turpentine
and
uh
uh oh people that were drinking um
hydrogen peroxide like there's so many
it's like you would literally be like
all right listen here's this safe thing
to do
and like no no i don't want to take that
and um
the videos i do try to
try to take a snapshot of those of those
events or those moments and then kind of
write them into a story you know within
a minute 60 seconds or like within 60
seconds or so
so i mean it's a good point because what
you're talking about in a lot of your
videos are like serious
real [ __ ] issues and
some of it is laughable you know it's
easy to mock like you're saying it's
easy to mock but sometimes it's not hard
to mock them because they are saying the
thing
that you are trying to say in the video
but they're saying it the way that you
would say it like it's like you are the
satire what the satire is [ __ ] dead
right right yeah yeah so we had a huge
example of that like back in 2000 uh and
an eight really all the way back then
when john mccain selected sarah palin
and
and they would stand on saturday live
she would stand there and she would just
say the same things that sarah palin
said the night before in an interview
and everyone's like
and it was like that's exactly what she
said almost the same cadence of how she
said it
tina fey is just doing a a really silly
facial expression maybe an
over-exaggerated facial expression and
movements but she's saying almost the
exact same thing in the exact same
cadence that she said it it's it was
alarming
yeah it's pretty it's one of those
things you know like you look at snl and
you're like all right what
what topic you know current event or or
trending kind of thing that's being
talked about are they going to
you know mock make fun of or you know
adapt to do a parody or satire whatever
and
[Music]
yeah back in 2008 you see tina fey doing
literally what you know sarah palin said
then you fast forward to 2020
you know even 2016 too as well you know
they had a lot of mocking stuff between
the debates uh between trump and you
know hillary clinton uh and then you
fast forward to 2020 and it's like
every
i feel like 2020 and everyone was at
their home and was watching everything
happen in real time and everyone did
have the question of like is this real
life is this satire i don't know anymore
and then you watch it on snl or someone
else on like another political kind of
uh comedy talk show
and they're just
pulling the truth from what was
literally said
and maybe exaggerating a little bit you
know like the fly in pence's head was
ended up being joe biden
on his head
and herman cain was on there right but
it's like those are real things that are
being made fun of from real events
and
uh it's also funny just see that whole
the right or the base look at it and be
like
and reject it to be
that never happened that was never said
that was an exaggeration that was a joke
you know that's that's not what he meant
and it's like
how
like what world what reality do you live
in that you are unable to just like
you're able to watch it but not able to
really
see
or accept it you know
well and a good example is i know you
posted and i think i had it on
a twitch stream that i did the other day
uh where you posted a video
uh because donald trump put out this big
statement that their new slogan is make
america great again again and again and
again and again and maybe again maybe
again but probably never right probably
never again but right but you actually
you found this clip from it was the 2020
campaign right
yeah he was in i think it was new
hampshire it was october 2020 and he
sees a guy in the crowd
and he's like uh yeah you got that you
know make america great again hat and
he's like i'm gonna throw it i'm gonna
throw another again on there it's gonna
make america great again again
and it sounds ridiculous because even
even the slogan itself like that slogan
he stole from ronald reagan and during
the 1980 campaign which was like let's
make america great again
and then you know classic trump he just
goes uh i'll just take someone else's
thing and and and uh and take credit for
it and so it was let's make america
great again to make america great again
and he has
the
he's like unable to have an original
thought so he goes well you know what
make america great again worked so we
throw on comma again
and in the video he says that he jokes
about it and everyone's like oh cheering
you know and they laugh about it and he
literally says
i'm gonna throw another again on there
so i can
sell you another hat
and i know that was one of the biggest
things that they they talked about
during the campaign they're like oh we
sold over a million you know make
america great again hats
and it's all a grift and they're
literally there and they're like oh he's
laughing he's he must be joking okay
that's funny we'll all laugh but he's
like no he literally told you his intent
and then he did it
and you're gonna buy it up and you're
gonna eat it you know why i mean i think
that's almost
the entire
from 2015 really when he announced all
the way up until now oh yeah it's
continued to be grift i mean i i and
i've said this several times on the
podcast and i've tweeted out that we are
we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life here like
literally
the ivermectin store is on one corner
and the the the [ __ ] rnc
cpac going going to
uh hungary is on the other corner like
what in the hell is happening like how
can you how can you even think to make
this [ __ ] up and that's really that's
the tough part for comedians like you
now i use a lot of comedy i'm more i
consider myself more of a commentator
who uses comedy but you are you are
writing this comedy and it must be
difficult to write the comedy speaking
speaking of grifters and writing comedy
and someone with the name
donald trump you have a video
uh with don jr in it and he's
looks like he's grifting in it because a
while back you know everyone's wondering
if these people are running out of money
which of course they they probably are
but don jr gets on cameo and he was
charging like
like 500 bucks or something i don't know
what he was changing he's still he still
is i think he's actually charging more
than that and like even more for like
the 24 hour turnaround kind of thing i
mean they're all on cameo as like how do
you make a quick buck to say
the most simple things like what maybe
maybe we should go on cameo i i have you
consider i i think maybe we should go on
cameo i could do i could just say [ __ ]
them
and into the you know [ __ ] um oh it's
your birthday [ __ ] them and i could you
know griff to be i don't know maybe
someone would pay me 20 30 bucks to do
that i don't know i doubt it but i i
just i find it funny that that it's not
just like him it's his entire universe
around him
that has gotten into this grift and i
think that's a lot of this ivermectin
facebook it's all one big huge [ __ ]
grift for someone to make money
somewhere and if he gets part of it
great if he doesn't you know maybe his
supporters will so but i do want to play
a grifter video that you did a while
back how do you know how old this video
is
it had to have been right when he did
the cameo so it's got to be from the
summer right
uh not too yeah yeah probably the last
couple months so this is this is this is
gabe's rendition of
a don junior cameo video so let's don jr
and uh this cameo goes out to a fellow
patriot by the name of uh
ima
lou
sir am i standing right is it emers and
ima because i think it said i'm a i'm a
lou sir
anyway i just want to wish you i'm a
happy birthday and uh uh
you look great for
line
you look great for 40.
eric get out of the trash i told you
that pizza has mold on it
line
this is the best part when he calls for
lime but it's not it's not what you
think it's it's exactly what you think
yeah
so so how do you because man i'm i'm
gonna be honest with you like the makeup
is spot-on or maybe it's not makeup how
much coke did you have to do or what did
you have to do to prepare to look like
don junior
yeah i set up a whole nother business to
just completely expense those business
items you know as research if you will
do your own research right yeah um but
no it's the the makeup and i will say
like the the
the purpose or the goal of the videos is
like i want to create a world right like
how however ridiculous or outrageous
the scenario is that they're in
like i want to create some realness to
it and there are some people on you know
antique talk and twitter or whatever and
instagram that make videos and they're
just like i'll put a like a little like
uh towel on my head and i'll be the girl
or like i'll
go from the other angle and it's like oh
here's like a quick back and forth but
with my videos you know in and those
videos work they're totally fine uh but
for my style i i really want to create
that world and to do that
you know i put in design you know i'm a
designer so i'll put in design to link
different props like like you saw with
the ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine and you know all the
different things like i'm putting time
in to like add those little details
because i feel like it enriches the the
video um especially for the viewer uh
and sometimes i'll like hide little
easter eggs in there and
um
but they
they take some time like it's there's
the writing process and then there's the
whole like all right what what props am
i going to use in here and for like don
jr you know i'm putting on
uh
it's a combination of burning and the
secret here for anyone who wants to know
the secret is you're burning a cork
uh and then you're rubbing it on your
face to create that kind of that five
o'clock shadow that beard and then i'm
taking like flour for instance so i'm
like digging through my my girlfriend's
like flower staff just like
i put it on my face
um that's the coke obviously that's the
coke right yeah yeah that is the because
you're not you're not using real cocaine
i mean it's not a you know you just
don't rock down the street to your
dealer okay well
a lot of people ask me like how i get my
eyes so red and they're like either you
irritated them that much or you're
really on coke
uh but that is another prop that i do um
noah like it's all these are all
practical effects there's no like
special effects in these videos um it's
putting stuff in my eyes
putting flour on my face
uh and on my jacket and everything
and again it's to sell the idea that
um
this is that character in that scenario
and in this one it's it's don jr and
he's trying to make a quick buck by
selling a cameo and
can't quite you know
uh pick up on the joke that he's that
he's a part of
um
so yeah it's it's a process it takes
some time especially trying to figure
out like oh i've got this idea and then
how do i create that character
and what like
kind of tools or aid do i need to
to make it go forward
so so i i do notice that you put a lot
of time into your props in your videos
but one of my favorite props one of my
favorite props is the the trump hat um
obviously i'm wearing a red hat because
i want to make red hats wearable again
yeah
but you you
you have different renditions
of the of the hat and and there seems to
be like an evolution of this of the
manga hat inside your videos
and
to go back to the don junior because
there was one point i want to make and
then we'll get to the hats yeah was was
the script that the cameo that you would
have paid for was that the
yeah that's what i would have liked so
so you wanted the don junior video
without having to pay for it it's kind
of the yeah i got you okay good yeah i
wanted to figure out a way how to be
like if i were to make a video
you know how do i sneak in a word that
if he says it
at a certain cadence that it would
actually be a different
a different thing altogether it was
fantastic so let's talk about the red
hat tell me about the red hat the manga
hat evolution because again in your
videos
you know originally it would say like
keep america great or make america
whatever it was an actual you would you
would try to emulate a maga hat which
the most beautiful part about it is that
like you're not trying to make it look
like the real manga hat you're trying to
make it look
to me it seems like in the video like a
mock a trump humper
is like how do i make my own maga hat
and you know and that's how they would
make it that's that's what i see is
happening but there's been like this
evolution from
from uh make america or whatever it says
originally on it i think you had make
america gradient and then it's involved
so tell us about the evolution of the
hat and how you come up with that so
i've got a i've got a red hat uh it's
the uh el paso chihuahuas the uh minor
league baseball team
and
even better even better yeah uh and so i
i would slap on a um
a little red piece of paper that said
make america great again and for a while
i had that on there and i had and people
would comment
um be like oh my god i can't believe you
paid for that you know i would never
give in to my money and all this stuff
people people came at me pretty hard for
it and i was like
it's literally a piece of paper with
duct tape on the back and that's stuck
on a hat i don't know what you got to
talk about the most i've i've allowed
myself to to dedicate to this is the ink
that i put in my ink or into my printer
and i i printed out and i cut it out and
i put it on that was the most fun effort
and
over time it got like watermarks and it
was like got a little wrinkled and kind
of torns which i felt like added a
little right it's perfect yeah right
yeah uh but it definitely started with
the whole like was like i'm never gonna
give give this group money for this hat
that is a symbol of hate right like it's
terrible i don't want to do that
um
i also whenever i still film these
outside and i do a lot behind the green
in front of the green screen now but
whenever i do do them outside uh i am
still very conscious of the hat that i'm
wearing even though it's a complete joke
and i'll like take the hat off when
someone walks by with complete fear that
they think that i actually am a part of
this group um or like take the sticker
off and be like a little chihuahua in
there um
but which is not any better but you know
right but i'm like
if anyone asks like it's not the same
you know right so people people got mad
about it and
um
i was like okay well
i don't know why i'm still using my
platform like even though their platform
is much bigger i'm not i don't know why
i'm still using my platform to like
um
lift up or or
or boost their message
so then i started creating um
alternative
slogans on there and uh two that i
remember that i have right now
are um i'm a huge hypocrite
and the other one is i'm a simp for
right-wing terrorists and then i've got
another one i think that says like i
can't read
um
but i you know it's just like
you take what they say and
you know you can spin it however way you
want and it's just funny
and i feel like i wear more the i'm a
huge hypocrite especially now with all
these people
that are you know
will say one thing you know they're like
i'm pro-choice but you know i say i'm
pro-life versus vaccine versus abortion
versus this versus that like whatever
the topic is they'll flops like a pair
of sandals you know they'll like say one
thing and then the complete opposite say
nothing that contradicts what what they
just said
um
so i feel like that head gets a lot more
uh stage time if i ever do like an
insurrectionist or just like another
video that doesn't do with that then
i'll probably put on like i'm a simp for
right-wing terrorists
um
but yeah it's always i'm just like if
i'm gonna wear the red hat i'm gonna put
a message on there that i think is funny
and it's gonna make fun of them you know
it's gonna mock them um
for this hat that they like live and die
by you know
so so let me ask you because uh you make
a good point back to
uh you know which hat you're wearing and
then back to the like now they're
like this hat has
just like the evolution of your hat in
your videos this hat has gone to
symbolize symbolized different things as
the as we've evolved since you know
really 2015 but really since he started
his 2020 campaign it really evolved into
a lot of different things with the
pandemic
and we are at a point like the point you
just made uh in our political discourse
where
it is complete hypocrisy like
not just not just with one thing but
it's like all things
like everything can you imagine if the
democratic national committee decided to
do
their big huge the democrats and the
liberals decided to do their big huge
conference and go to a foreign country
can you even
[ __ ] imagine
and they're ext they're loving this
they're like oh this is gonna be great
because we're gonna go where like
basically
21st century neo-nazis are at like this
is this is the right wing this is
fascist yeah 2.0 there this is going to
be great we're going to learn from the
best
right but what's also funny is they'll
do those things and then they'll they'll
in the same breath
call anyone who calls that out be like
you're fascist you're trying to control
my freedom of speech my freedoms and
it's like name the rest of the
amendments if you can right uh but
it really like within
within the same breath they'll just be
like uh yeah we'll go to a place or
we'll we'll represent or support this
person that has these ideologies which
at one point you would be like that is
anti-american anti-democratic like all
this stuff right
and then be like
oh no
you're calling that out now you're the
problem
you're you're the you're the sheep and
it's like
what goes back to your video
right it goes back to your video you're
actually eating stuff for livestock it's
insanity insanity the level of satire
that you are actually portraying in real
life is incredible
but but even like
because it gets me
even on levels of you know my body my
choice but it even is more simple than
that i i posted something this morning
and i don't remember what i said i i
said uh something about the the
the pfizer vaccine um and i guess
project veritas and of course this is
going to be a stupid thing that we do
over the next week they have a video of
what appears to be
what they're saying is a scientist with
pfizer which they may or may not be i
don't know but literally the person is
saying everything that we've already
known for months and months
that the vaccine isn't a hundred percent
it's not a hundred percent there's gonna
be breakthrough we've known that since
the very beginning they've said that
even last year before it was even had
the emergency approval from the fda
after they did all the r d and had the
data they knew what the data was they
knew that there was going to be
breakthrough
the other thing that he really that they
try to zero in on is oh my god the virus
gives you antibodies like yeah that's
how your [ __ ] immune system works
like how the [ __ ] can't you people know
this like if it doesn't kill you
if it doesn't kill you you will have
antibodies from having the virus because
your body fought it off now what he's
explaining in the video is like those
antibodies are completely different than
the antibodies we're giving you because
it interacts with the protein
differently and that's why you don't get
sick when you have like these literally
explained him why to get the vaccine
like yeah like like the video clip that
they show is like that's the evidence of
why to get it
right like why
so the funny part is and i guess the
point here is is that i said
obviously the point is is the goal is
for no one to get the virus like it's
not gonna that's the goal it's not weak
it's not achievable
because it's a pandemic so obviously
there's gonna be breakthrough but if
everyone would do what they're supposed
to do and
listen to the scientists listen to
hundreds of years of historical data on
vaccines and vaccine mandates and people
how we eradicate disease in this country
like if you just look at not just covid
data like historically
on vaccines how you get rid of disease
in certain areas of the countries in
certain communities you would know this
stuff it's really simple it's not rocket
science but it but it's incredible and
that's kind of what i said the goal is
to not get it and then someone down
below is like yeah well it's our choice
not to get the vaccine so leave us the
hell alone and it's like yes we know
it's your choice to not get the vaccine
but what you're doing is saying you
don't want the consequences you want the
choice
but you don't want the consequences and
what really pisses me off when they've
tried because
these people appropriate everyone's
culture
and everyone they approach just like you
said donald trump steals everything this
this white privilege
uh white grievance [ __ ] they appropriate
every culture uh black culture in
america
uh hispanic culture and they appropriate
every [ __ ] culture and they try to
appropriate the phrase my body my choice
yeah and what they don't understand
because me
neither one of us are women we are we
are the least likely to get abortions
between
us right but what they and and mostly
this is men what they don't understand
is that women have never said i want the
choice to have abortion but i don't want
the consequences like do you have any
idea how much how many consequences
there are to choose to carry a child to
not to
to choose whether it's your life
or or or not to have an abortion i mean
don't do you i have any idea what those
consequences are of those choices and
that those women bear those consequences
of those choices and you [ __ ]
literally are saying a phrase that you
have no historical context of what the
phrase means oh and what the context is
and not only that you are not willing to
[ __ ] live with the consequence of
people who actually live
live by that [ __ ] phrase and have for
decades and decades
and it's like
it's just a whole another level of
hypocrisy and absolute absolutes
they're self unaware
um
yeah it's just incredible
it's uh there's a few things that you
mentioned so like the on the vaccine
side they're like oh well i i don't
wanna you know okay first off project
veritas a complete joke that has uh
every time someone's like oh
they got this
uh you know insider video you know it's
like uh this person was being recorded
and it was uh
um
it was like undercover kind of thing
and then you do a little bit of research
into
who the people are in the video and you
realize that
these videos are edited and manipulated
in a way just you know
a lot of things in life are manipulated
so that you can focus on emotion or
reaction from people but this is
definitely done in a malicious way
where
james o'keefe knows what he's doing
and does it intentionally
there was the there was the video that
came out before this one where they're
like oh there's the whistleblower that
was uh that worked for
um the us department of health and
services and she had the video of the
doctor in there who was like oh they're
you know it's full of [ __ ] there's a
bunch of [ __ ] in the back scene i'm
trying to make you take it and it's a
you know it's a bunch of these like
undercover videos
um between different people in the
hospital
i
out of curiosity
my my mom is a nurse and i you know i
respect the medical field and i have
complete admiration for it once almost
even consider becoming a doctor because
i spent so much time in a hospital like
with my mom
um
and i was like you know what this person
is giving a bad name for
years of research that we've done
in technology and has advanced to make a
vaccine for people
to fight a deadly virus this pandemic
and
i called into the hospital of where
it was the um
uh
phoenix
it was i think it's called piku picu or
but it was phoenix arizona um hospital
that was specifically also within um
within like indigenous people like
reservation area so it's also a very
vulnerable population so to release a
video of a doctor saying this in a
hospital in that area
is very very bad um
and so i called in and i was curious i
was like hey i'm you know i use an alias
not my real name uh i say this is so and
so i'm following up on a video that was
released but this person claimed this
and i wanted to see what they said
anyway find out that the woman in the
video this doctor uh
forget her name maria i think gutierrez
or gonzalez or yeah gonzalez
yeah
um
she's not a full-time doctor she's a
part-time doctor who as the person who
at hr i spoke to
moonlights there
when they need an open slot
so she's a
whoever has their own opinion doesn't
work for the department of health and
services doesn't work for this hospital
uh is a part-time person who just kind
of
subs in when they need someone to fill a
slot for a shift
and this person just like running her
mouth and saying like oh the vaccine's
full of [ __ ] it's not it's not uh
helpful it's com it's harmful
very very dangerous language
um
and finding out also that
just like none of the stuff that is said
is true but it doesn't matter to someone
like james o'keefe and project veritas
they do the same thing with his video to
say to to make the case of why you need
the vaccine
but to try to make it proposed as like
oh the vaccine is actually harmful and
bad for you you shouldn't take it
because it you know changes your dna and
all these crazy claims that they make
when in actuality it's like no this is
based on years of research like you said
this is based on clinical data and
testing and approval and committees and
and
uh
also
the people that say they don't want the
vaccine for covid
were completely fine if they were
enlisted in the military getting shot up
with everything you can think of to make
sure that they're safe in foreign
countries for those
local
diseases
uh but also
if you were a kid right you had to have
a literal like you know vaccine kind of
report card that you turned in to say
yeah i've been vaccinated for
measles and mumps and chickenpox and
polio and all this stuff so i don't or
this kid doesn't cause an outbreak for a
bunch of these other people uh teachers
or or staff members or students
uh even more so for people who travel
you're like
you need to prove that you've been
vaccinated to travel to a foreign
country certain like china and other
places um
this vaccine is no different it's just
that technology made it much quicker
based on
uh existing technology and you compound
that
you know with time and you're able to
accelerate and get something out quicker
and also how they you know streamlined
um the whole process but the people
still despite
having this uh information readily
available they'll deny it
till
till they're buried in the grave you
know and and they'll just fight it to be
like
my body my choice and it's like you
clearly don't get the message
and you also claim that you're mocking
this group
but if you were to have an argument or
conversation whatever you want to call
it with someone that was that was saying
that they were my body my choice and try
to get them to agree on it then it's
like okay if you're my my body my choice
for the vaccine then you're also my body
my choice for a woman's reproductive
rights to choose if she wants to have an
abortion
and there's like no that's not the same
thing and it's like okay fine if you're
not
pro-choice for that
then are you willing to support and give
the necessary social services and
programs to these women who now have to
have a child because you wouldn't allow
an abortion and like oh no no no i
wouldn't do that so it's like what are
you guys are you pro-life you pro-choice
because i'm getting a complete
uh contradiction between two things you
said within the same breath
well you know i think that's a good
point because and i've said this before
they actually
they've never really believed any of
this [ __ ] and and they don't know what
they believe anymore and that's why
they're in these corners right they
painted themselves in these corners and
really i think that's the actual danger
is that they painted themselves in these
corners and that they might act out on
some of these things when they really
truly don't believe them right like they
like they don't believe this stuff and
it would be dangerous for them to act
out on them i mean in the same way that
project veritas is kind of poking the
bear here because yeah for for all
intents and purposes i i don't know who
this scientist is he could be the guy
that mops the floors why the scientists
are having meetings right right i don't
know and he may be a scientist i don't
know now the things he said in the video
that i the clip that i watched of course
i won't even play it here and i didn't
play it on any of my content because
it's because there it actually to me
it's like well that makes you think you
should get the vaccine but you know
whatever you know it's crazy how they
turn things around
but speaking of like you said the lady
from the hospital where their one video
um
it almost feels like we have some of
these people in congress and what i mean
by that is central casting right like
lauren bobert marjorie taylor greene
matt gatz like some of these people
it feels like they auditioned to be
right wingers and they got the part and
they placed them in these congressional
districts and that's how we got some of
these [ __ ] fools is that
because and there's evidence that like
candace owens and some of these other
right-wingers that aren't in congress
yeah yeah right they were all in
right right they had casting profiles
a talent profile right so and i don't
know if that's i maybe that's a
conspiracy theory
but
even if it is a conspiracy theory
sometimes conspiracy theories you're
like well
it's no wonder it's a conspiracy theory
because it seems so obvious right which
brings me to
my next video that i have of yours of a
congressman who seems like he's from the
casting agent the the nazi casting
agency
uh
he's a florida man of course
it's uh matt gatz and i believe this
video is where
matt gatz ends up in hell which you know
is i'm an atheist but i would believe
that if there
was a hell
there would probably be a special place
for matt gates in it so let me play that
and then we'll talk about that video
whoa
where am i the gates of hell like the
mad gates of hell hell no i shouldn't be
here i'm a good innocent christian
innocent people don't beg trump for a
blanket pardon but sure let's go through
the list list in 2017 you are the only
congressman to vote no on the anti-human
trafficking bill well the thing about uh
in 2019 you tweeted that florida should
change with welcome signs to there's no
age that you can't be sexy recently you
made fake ideas with joel greenberg a
sex trafficker fake news there's video
evidence then you show nude photos of
women to other lawmakers on the house
floor there's a very good explanation
shut the hell up i'm not done yet
turns out you also created a sleazy sex
game with fellow florida lawmakers and
you also paid to have sex with minors
even we think that's gross
don't fight it we literally have the
receipts i mean how [ __ ] dumb do you
have to be to pay for sex with an app
right on schedule
little nasdaq will now be in charge of
your punishment
[Laughter]
of course
you land you land a great punch again
and again and again um every time with
these videos so you went after uh matt i
call him matt getz everyone wants to say
gates but the reason why i call him gets
and i [ __ ] up name names on purpose
but i call him matt getz because
i think it would piss him off
yeah so for sure so any video that i
might do or that might get out there i
want to make sure it's matt getz because
he'd be like if he saw solid he'd be
pissed not about the content because it
would probably be true but that right i
said his [ __ ] name wrong you know so
it's matt gatz but i get the whole gates
of hell i get the
the thing there that you did but but
really this goes back
your video is really talking about again
this theme of hypocrisy where
like every single time uh uh there's
even a sneeze that a democrat did
something wrong the entire the entire
right wing destroys them and not only
the entire right wing but
there's always this this part of the
democrat or liberal part of the
political spectrum that wants to be
again the woke or the the head of
everyone else or you know because that's
our cycle today's you got to be you got
to be first in line right i knew before
everyone else knew right so there's this
cycle so they destroy that person right
but when you flip it around when you
turn it around and it's a right winger
especially
uh a trump-humping
you know
supposedly christian evangelical person
like
oh man that's a it makes a little throw
up in my mouth when i say that about
something like matt gates yeah but even
when that happens and we have this case
and it's a federal case this isn't like
this isn't like some hyperbole or some
meme this is a real case where someone
that evidence ties to matt matt gets
joel greenberg has has
admitted guilt in a federal court and
not only that to several charges and it
seems to be providing evidence and the
public evidence shows that matt gets
possibly probably 100 percent committed
allegedly committed federal crimes
yeah right out of the
audience and so this hypocrisy i mean
and and that's is that where this video
came from or or talk about that
uh there's actually it's uh i actually
have it there's like a two-parter to
this video i have another video where uh
chris hansen uh meets matt gates in a in
a kitchen and he's like how about you
take a seat right and that's how the
typical uh catch a predator that's right
editor yes starts right and so he comes
in and he you know
he's like oh i've never heard of joel
greenberg and he's like well here's a
photo of you with him and roger stone
and he's like oh it's you know basically
it's
it's a campaign of people uh to come
against him and attack him right
and
uh so there's another video where i i
hit on that because i'm like sooner or
later
like this is the scenario it would have
led to right if he wasn't already
uh
under investigation like i'm sure
somebody would have
gotten him on tape in a very
compromising situation where he was
doing something
that he should not have been doing
um so there's another one like that but
this one yeah so these videos really
came out of of this idea and i even have
another one which is
calling out um
uh
you know cuomo right and being like you
know the right is like oh the you know
andrew crumble should resign like yeah
he should anyone who who does something
against
a female male or whoever
should be prosecuted and and should go
through um
an investigation
uh no one's saying they shouldn't right
especially on on the left everyone's
like yeah if this person did something
like this
they assaulted someone um harassed
whatever they should face the
consequences right
and
then you're like great how about you
take that same energy that you have
against cuomo
and you put it against matt gates and
jim jordan and and all these other
people who
are you know uh definitely showed signs
or they have evidence against them
um of you know explicitly making venmo
payments right and it's
the complete just like
blinders that they have on to be like
no no i that's not the same thing that
it's completely different right and or
or even like when the right was like oh
al franken you gotta resign over this
photo right um
and then he was like okay you know i'll
resign you know i
i'll do what i do i feel like it's the
right thing to do whether it is right or
not whatever
um
and then the right is unable
to accept
you know for the also for the party that
is very much like
sex like we don't uh
we don't want sex traffickers and we
want to save the children and all that
[ __ ] that they that they just like
uh project out there they are unwilling
to accept any fault or blame within
their own party
and it's just like if there was any more
of a sign that this gop gqp whatever you
want to call them
are hypocrites uh you know they can
contradict themselves
um they
you know are just like unwilling to to
face the truth or or they know it's true
and they will you know you know divert
their eyes somewhere else and place the
blame and point at the next shiny new
thing or whatever it is
um
and it's across the board it's on a
myriad of topics but this one in
particular which like this is a very bad
offense this is something that's very
very bad
uh
and they just do not accept
fault or blame within their own party
for those within it
uh and matt gates is a a perfect example
of that and in those moments
um
i'm just like yeah this is the
inspiration for this video or these
videos where it's like can we call to
attention the hypocrisy here like i
don't i don't know how many different
ways i need to say it but uh
the guy's in the wrong he did something
bad he should face the consequences and
the other party's like what what
and just like
don't want to
don't want to accept it you know nope
don't do it won't do you know what i you
know what i i have a phrase for this
you know what i call this condition that
they have
i call it head up ass syndrome um
because because they do they need to
pluck their head out of their [ __ ]
asses it's head up fastener but there's
also the the technical term i think is
annual cranial dysfunction i'm not sure
on that
uh maybe maybe we'll have to check the
medical dictionary on that but but
that's also the there's also the trump
derangement syndrome which is
they're so
bought into
the trump that he could never do any
wrong right and it's the people who you
know stormed the capital and
name change then i have a i have another
sketch where there's a guy who goes to a
doctor and he gets diagnosed and the
guy's like you're you've got tds and
he's like titty ass and he's like no tds
trump derangement syndrome
and he explains like you named your
child uh like
ivanka
eric don jr
uh tiffany baron
trump right and all these other things
and
uh you were willing to
to go bankrupt and donate your money to
the guy for the grift and you knew it
and you still would do it
and
it's like that whole party they're all
just you know
they're like oh you guys the democrats
on the left or whatever all sheep and
it's like you guys
are doing exactly what you're accusing
everyone else of doing right like at the
same time it's like
you're you're like just like with the
trump hat thing it's like you're
literally told
what he's going to do and you laugh it
off
and then you put money down
and it's like
what
well you know the crazy part about that
is this week we're hearing all this
facebook stuff which i mean we i think
we've all known this facebook stuff for
a long time but the significance of it
is an actual whistleblower's not not
only coming out and say it that worked
at facebook um but she's providing the
receipts right and today she started in
congress 10 000 documents yeah it's
something crazy like and and basically
confirming uh what everyone knew now now
the big story that everyone's kind of
zeroed in on is the instagram young
girls thing um yeah but i i actually
think um that being a specific story
that's where they can get bipartisanship
in congress so i think that's a good
story to kind of focus on but really the
overall broad story is that
that
the algorithm isn't the enemy it really
isn't garbage in garbage out and the the
problem that we have is facebook knew
that and i think that's where a lot of
this [ __ ] comes from that's where a lot
of these this programming of them
they do they think donald trump is not
the guy who he really is like they have
this whole other image of what he is
which is not even close to the reality
and i think it's all the programming of
facebook and we're seeing that this week
where
um her name is uh uh hogan heughan hogan
hogan or
yeah
h-a-u-g-e-n so it's not hogan but i
think it's something somewhere there but
um
but she was she and it's not just like
facebook like the project veritas where
she swept the floors there and heard
these people say this
this woman has been in social media and
internet companies for for a long time
she worked for google um she was a pro a
huge project manager at pinterest and
she's got like a data science degree
like this is what she does
and she's basically risked her entire
career of ever working in her field
again to come out and say hey
not only is this wrong they [ __ ] knew
it was wrong
and that's i think the huge thing that
today under oath she sat in front of
congress and said hey
not only are they doing wrong and we all
and it's been obvious like yeah it's
been obvious that this is happening
we've seen tons of families tons of
lives being destroyed over this
misinformation and this reprogramming of
how the algorithms program to you but
the problem and i don't i everyone wants
to blame it on the algorithm and it is
the algorithms problem because facebook
could fix the algorithm but the problem
really is that facebook knows that this
is happening
they know it not not just to the extent
of that it's giving girls depression and
it and it's causing some of them to
commit suicide
it's like changing
it's like changing parts of society
because they're completely being
deprogrammed or reprogrammed however you
want to put it like you said earlier
you're the they do something fascist
you're like that's really fascist like
no you're the fascist because you called
me a fascist or or whatever the whatever
the hypocrisy is but what do you think
you know before we go what do you think
this facebook do you think that this
changes if congress can do something or
even the knowledge of this can change
and and un unengaged some of this this
garbage that we're talking about
it makes for less videos for you but
yeah in turn it makes society better
right yeah and who knows maybe i'll
write a a a video about this exact
situation but i can tell you from my own
experience i worked for a company uh
that was within
the social media space we were a
facebook partner company and we made a
facebook app and i can tell you i mean
like we had our own um
you know ip that we had uh
that would be predictive modeling it was
within the higher ed space and how
students made connections but i can tell
you from
people that we had connections with and
conversations we were privy to this is
like this is nothing new like this is
like the fact that i still use the app
it's like whatever because it was
popular time and it was the you know
outside of twitter and instagram those
are the main two things that were you
know used on social media
but um
it is nothing new like we knew these
things we knew that they were
programming
the app to be highly addictive you know
it works um
it's like also it's like justin
rosenstein is the creator of the like
button and just a few years ago
um he came out and he was like
i regret making that i
do not like the fact that i create a
like button because it has evolved and
created this monster on social media
which is like validation
comes from how many likes or hearts or
retweets or or shares or whatever it is
but it all came from the like button you
know the thumbs up
and
that's something to be said there which
is like if the creator of the thing
from facebook or on facebook says i
regret making that thing it's like the
creation of the atom bomb it's like i
it's the thing is a is a tool that
that it can be weaponized
and that is what happened and so i can
tell you from like
stuff that i knew back then it was early
stages but it was it was happening
you've got teams that are primarily
focused on the interaction of
just the you know just like
uh
the news section or just the
um the photos section or just the
uh the timeline or you know or your wall
or whatever um teams that are
that are with a scalpel
making slight tweaks
and testing with an audience because
their their user base is so large that
they can do tests
very quickly and they can validate
hypotheses that they have of
interactions that they're trying to
teach right new behaviors to say like we
want people to use this
will they do that what happens if we
slightly change the color or the text or
the size or what have you like these are
all things that you know i've
experienced in within product design in
product management and
software development
but these are things that are happening
behind the scenes and not a lot of
people understand what's going on but
there's a there's a a crazy world
of within facebook and all social media
that works within this hooked model
which is like you know you're giving
someone
a little taste they try it you know and
they go to the next thing and then
eventually you know you they're going in
a circle and they're hooked because
you've now taught them
that
they make an action
here's a response they receive a reward
they do that again and you go again and
again in a cycle that essentially never
ends that keeps people on the app you
know you want to bring your retention
numbers up and so when i look at this in
the end and i think to myself
what's going to happen from facebook
will they make changes
uh within on their own no way because
facebook is one of the largest lobbying
entities
in dc
so
it's it's like uh it's like south it's
like from the you know the pandora
papers it's like south dakota is a tax
haven and they're the ones that are
writing the tax laws that are going to
benefit their state
uh as a place to store your money right
and it's facebook is the same way where
they're gonna say
okay we'll make the changes
and you just have to take our word for
it and unless there's some sort of
regulation or you're able to break them
up from this monopolist like monopoly
that's there within this communication
social media platform
um
you have to take action so whether it's
breaking them up as like that's a clear
sign to
separate these powers so
you avoid a server issue like yesterday
which is literally everything's in the
same server room and the only way that
you can access it is going through with
a
um
with an axe grinder
which is a whole hilarious story on its
own to think that everything was stored
it was like how to get into buildings
how to you know instagram facebook
whatsapp all within one server room and
a lack of redundancy and a lo and no key
to get in the door they had to break in
but that's you know the whole thing by
its own
but as i look at it i say
there is no path forward
in my mind
unless there is some sort of regulation
or
um they they break up the company in
some way
um which you know funny enough people on
the right and the left have been saying
it for years
um it's just that the people that are
asking the questions in these committees
don't ever take action they're always
like oh hey what would you change if you
could change it and you guys are making
the rules so we'll take your word for it
and you've got a lot of people who are
just like
so old like you know uh uh blumenthal
who's like
so you guys gonna shut down the finsta
and you're like that's not even in the
app i don't know what you're talking
about that's
so it's it's there's a lack of
understanding within uh
lawmakers
and
that
allows this whole problem to evolve
where they're like oh well don't worry
don't we'll do it we'll do it and we
will we will tell you that uh it's fixed
and so i think without some sort of
regulation or someone breaking them up
or someone that's actually monitoring
this
to avoid these issues like there's some
litmus test or benchmark to say
here's a problem
and here are things that we can do to
solve it in your product to avoid these
very dangerous and terrible outcomes
within teens and females and whoever
i don't know if there's anything that
would change it they're gonna keep doing
it they knew it and the only reason they
kept doing it was because it was making
money
and that at the end of the day is the
driving force
if they can make more money they're
gonna keep doing that thing
even though they know they know that
it's wrong it's the immoral unethical
thing
and if it makes more money and it drives
shareholders money up and and the value
goes up
keep it going the other way keep the atm
a ticking well and i think i think the
answer is um because i i mean
breaking it up sounds great and maybe
that's part of the solution part of the
solution
but it is a utility so it is
i view it as utility and not facebook
itself but social media in general
because a lot of government entities um
emergency entities businesses
schools try to get their messaging out
to
their customers or their you know their
patrons in other words um about certain
things it's it's a messaging platform
it's like a newspaper we don't have
newspapers anymore so yeah it is like a
utility inside of utility where the
internet's kind of the you know the
physical lines buried in the in the
ground that is distributed to you and
it's a utility inside you do it so i
really think the regulatory body is what
needs to happen
um yeah and a good and a good example of
this is uh is utility companies like you
brought up is like pg e right a private
entity in california
they had no oversight or right if there
were any questions they were like yeah
we fixed it we did it you know and you
just have to take our word for it right
you fast forward to well i guess go back
a couple years now
and you've got a fire that goes up and
down the coast that goes for miles
because
of a pg e issue on their end right they
cause a spark in a fire and it's a hot
it's a fire season and it caused acres
of damage and people lose people passed
away yeah and they're just like oh my
bad and then you you have a watchdog
report that comes out that says oh
actually there were these issues that
were brought up and they knew about it
right and instead of regulating
themselves
and regulating they're like oh you know
what we're gonna give the ceo or this
executive person a bonus you know and
then they're like
you know same thing with like uh the
airline industry
you give them money after you know uh
they're like hey we're on the brink of
of uh
of
bankruptcy we need your money okay great
okay now you're going to use this money
for what you said right like yeah yeah
yeah and then you're like
yeah and then you get back wifi
oh yeah right oh we're going to do stock
buybacks and put profit in our pockets
and oh by the way we're going to raise
the price your ticket and charge you for
more baggage exactly you [ __ ] so it's
just like one of those things it's like
there are agencies but there needs to be
better regulation then you got people on
the right which i guarantee if you have
this conversation with someone on the
right and you try to go through this it
would be much like the videos that i've
done it's to be a looped conversation
right where you're going to talk about
uh hey facebook is too big yes you all
agree on that yeah right let's break it
up okay yeah we need regulation yeah and
they're like
uh and they might say yes on that one
and you go well if that's true
and let's apply the same logic right to
these other utilities and other things
and they're like no okay that's just and
then the right that's socialism well and
that's because they hate facebook right
now because the their the cheeto dust
mobster is not on there
i mean i mean literally they would love
twitter and facebook and they would be
on their side if donald trump was still
on there but because he's suing them now
it has to be the enemy like
well i mean i gotta do the go through
the whole show you know just like we
were saying earlier so that's that's the
whole thing right that's the whole
shtick they gotta they gotta pretend
like they hate it because they have to
hate it because it hates him or whatever
the [ __ ] they're they're they're
everywhere every day or week it's a
brand new um
fabricated
uh
anger right yeah and you could say that
you could say that on either side of the
political spectrum or whatever but
for
this side specifically they're like
uh freedom of speech and like but right
when a private company says that i can't
say these really bad things i want them
right it's it's craziness and it's they
totally stay in it right they totally
don't understand rights freedom or what
we actually want to achieve which is
liberty and i think that's the problem
is they don't understand liberty and
that liberty is only delivered to you if
everyone else has liberty that's the
only way that it's delivered to you and
they don't really they
because they're fascist and they've been
programmed by facebook and social media
to be fascist then that's the case
speaking of being programmed by social
media and social media programming
what i want you now that we've done bash
social media what i want you to do now
gabe
is to tell everyone out there where to
find you on social media so you can
program them with your con
with your content
yeah
so uh
my username across all platforms um
instagram uh you know when it's working
uh tik tok and twitter is i am gabe
sanchez very simple it's just my name
um you know consistent branding
uh but yeah you can find me on on all
those platforms you know tweets videos
sketches whatever they might be
um
you know political
not political just a
wide spectrum of content within the
within the comedy but also you know
hopefully somewhat educational and
insightful
awesome well i really do appreciate you
joining us and everyone out there if you
get a chance to go to gabe's tick tock i
really do suggest you you rewind all the
way back to the beginning of the
pentagon because there are some great
dance videos that you will love and you
should spread around
i'm not i'm not saying you should spread
them around all your social media
channels but we definitely might
consider it to get back to all those
thanks for joining me again today buddy
i really do appreciate you joining us
having you here stick around i'll catch
you on the other side here real quick
all right sounds good
all right gabe sanchez thank you very
much for joining us great conversations
um and gabe's really his videos the best
part about them that i like the most
about his videos is that they do cause
you to think about these issues in a way
that that is in a loop and a lot of
times when you watch him on tiktok it is
like a loop like you could watch the
same video of him
you know in the back and forth sketch
with him and a a manga trump bumper and
like you can watch it in a loop and it's
like a real thing like this is the
conversation that you would have with
someone who has this point
hypocrisy
hypocrisy and this point of view and
it's just like this big huge [ __ ]
cycle and loop with these people it's
insane so go go check his stuff out
again he's uh at i am gabe sanchez on
twitter uh tick tock and and the
instagrams
when they're not shredding records and
have their servers down while they're
shredding records because they're under
investigation by congress but he is over
there and i'm sure he protects his data
probably not but but uh i'll digress on
the social media so thanks gabe for
joining us again this episode we
we record it it's a special guest
episode we're gonna air it on friday
three o'clock central uh uh four o'clock
eastern and you already know that
because you've been here but all of our
special guest episodes that's how we air
them as we do them on friday three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern and
don't forget to join us on the live
podcast that's wednesdays three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern on youtube
twitter and twitch and you can also find
us on all
all the directories so the the apples
the spotifys the whole the whole nine
yards so catch us there uh please like
subscribe do all that kind of good
social media stuff that you know where
we're programming people's minds and
turning them into to uh vaccinated
zombies
and before i leave there's one last
thing i want to say [ __ ] them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them